en estas imágenes de satélite cientos de
vehículos militares atraviesan la
pequeña ciudad de beliki burlock en
Ucrania es un convoy del ejército ruso
probablemente procedente la ciudad de
harkif un poco más al oeste
harkif donde se Libra La batalla según
el gobernador de la provincia la ciudad
y sus suburbios han sido bombardeados
casi 70 veces en las últimas 24 horas
los civiles son las principales víctimas
me golpearon en la cabeza y la onda
expansiva me lanzó hacia atrás las
escaleras se derrumbaron las ventanas y
las puertas estallaron es un milagro que
haya sobrevivido
en más al este estos ucranianos saben
que el enemigo ruso se está acercando
para que los soldados y voluntarios se
preparen fortificación de posiciones
preparación de trincheras e instalación
de obstáculos antitanque esta localidad
rural podría convertirse en un enorme
campo de batalla en los próximos días
durante la la Segunda Guerra Mundial la
mayor batalla de tanques tuvo lugar aquí
y creo que la historia se repetirá habrá
muchas tropas era una zona de combate
hasta entonces las autoridades están
organizando las evacuaciones de civiles
vuelonski dijo el sábado que Ucrania
estaba preparada para luchar y que se
enfrentaría a grandes batallas en el
este desde el 25 de marzo Rusia río
orientado sus objetivos militares en el
este para recuperar el control total de
las regiones separatistas de donías Y
logans esto no impide que Moscú golpee
otras ciudades del país